comme la ministre la parole est un
monsieur philippe gosselin merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
nous sommes tous comme tant de familles
et de nos concitoyens sous le choc et la
colère nuls difficultés à se retrouver
dans cette unité nationale je crois que
tout ce qui nous unit nous grandit pour
autant un certain nombre de questions se
posent
le président de la république veut
renforcer le contrôle aux frontières et
c'est très bien
la principale administrations en charge
du contrôle des flux transfrontaliers
c'est la douane
l'as douanes effectuent des contrôles
globaux de personnes de bagages de
moyens de transport en tout point du
territoire
mais les douanes françaises réalisent
aussi des contrôles douaniers
d'immigration dans 82 points de passage
frontaliers sur sur 130 début 2015 70
emplois avaient été annoncées dans cette
administration pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et le projet de budget que
nous sommes en train d'examiner
évidemment ne va pas dans ce sens
pourtant les douanes françaises ont
besoin d'un d'éléments cruciaux
d'effectifs de moyens le plan dit
stratégiques des douanes ps dès 2013
2018 est actuellement en cours d'eau
oeuvre et aucun bilan du reste de la
délinquance aux frontières aucune étude
d'impact n'a été précédée n'a précédé ce
plan
si on le maintenait il y aurait
évidemment de grandes fermeture de
brigade unité de garde-côtes et je crois
qu'on ne peut évidemment le garder en
l'état il est en décalage complet avec
la réalité des leurres monsieur le
premier ministre ma question est simple
et elle reprend une question écrite que
je vous avais envoyé le 10 novembre
trois jours avant les lâches attentats
au delà des 1000 postes qui ont été
annoncés lundi par le président de la
république le plan stratégique des
douanes 2018 a vécu at il vécu notamment
en ce qui concerne les fermetures
d'unités terrestre aéroterrestre et de
garde-côtes
allez vous l'annulez le suspendre le
réviser quel le moyen comptez-vous
attribués aux douanes françaises
gardiennes de nos frontières notamment
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget monsieur le
président
député gosses l'amener à messieurs les
députés je vous remercie de votre
question qui me permets d'insister sur
le rôle de la douane dans un certain
nombre de ses missions et vous avez
évoqué celle des missions de contrôle
aux frontières
seize mille personnes en uniforme qui
représente d'ailleurs une cible parfois
pour des attentats potentiels il faut le
savoir dès vendredi nous avions renforcé
vendredi matin nous avions renforcé les
contrôles douaniers aux prévisions de la
coop 21 et bien entendu après la
tragédie de la nuit de vendredi à samedi
nous avons encore renforcé les contrôles
aux frontières ce qui nécessite un
engagement très fort des douaniers avec
michel sapin nous avions dès samedi en
fin de journée visiter la cellule de
crise qui avait été mise en place une
avion mesure est d'ailleurs la bonne
coopération et les apports intéressants
dans le cadre des enquêtes en cours des
échanges d'informations c'est essentiel
c'est peu souvent dit hier soir j'étais
rendre visite à à loin dans la banlieue
lilloise à nos équipes à nos brigades
sur le terrain chez mesuraient leur
difficulté parce qu'on remet en place
des contrôles dans des endroits où les
postes de douane ont disparu ou les
aires de stockage ont disparu souvent
sur des axes où le trafic international
la circulation des marchandises mais
aussi les personnes le travail
frontalier est une vraie réalité et on
le mesure les nos concitoyens les
mesures et il nous faut trouver le bon
équilibre 1000 emplois supplémentaires
ont été annoncées par le président de la
république
en plus des 80 emplois que vous avez
mentionné dans votre question c'est bien
entendu pour nous l'assurance de pouvoir
avec des brigades totalement engagés sur
le terrain de remplir la mission et nous
verrons comment adapter le réseau à
cette nouvelle donne
avec les nouveaux objectifs que nous
sommes fils merci monsieur le ministre
cette belle séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue